[Music]
Andreas wickberg loves taking the
snowmobile to his house in the icy
reaches of Lapland all four houses in
his tiny Arctic Community rely on
satellite internet for 500 krona a month
about 50 bucks wickberg and his wife can
hole up at home with a satellite
internet connection fast enough to do
work calls by day and stream movies by
night on the morning of February the
24th 2022 he turned on his computer and
gulped down the news that Russian
President Vladimir Putin had begun an
invasion of Ukraine a little while later
his neighbor came round asking to borrow
his Wi-Fi code saying their internet
connection had dropped wickberg shared
the code and kept going at work 10
minutes later his connection dropped two
he checked all four modem lights were
off that meant it was no longer
communicating with a hulking great
geostationary satellite that beams down
82 individual spots across Europe and
Northern Africa more than 20 000 miles
above him in the sky it turned out his
was one tiny part of the biggest public
outage of satellite internet ever
recorded more than 45
000 modems had to be replaced yet it
would take 35 days for the Global
Communications company affected via sat
to even begin to say what it thought had
happened and 75 days for any country to
point the finger officially back on
Earth wickberg knew instantly what had
happened it had to be Russia
[Music]
a few hours earlier and several time
zones away on an overcast evening in
Austin Texas a senior buying set
official settled in at home for the
night automated alerts suddenly started
pinging indicating abnormal activity in
Ukraine modems across much of Europe
were unable to make an internet
connection
ViaSat workers tried to force offline
modems that seemed overwhelmed by
malicious traffic but more kept coming
they were playing satellite modem
whack-a-mole
the real Target was more than a thousand
miles and half a continent away from
Andreas wickberg's Lapland Hideaway
satellite Communications that Ukraine's
government Army and intelligence rely on
were down this catastrophic
Communications loss hampered their
defenses backup came later in the form
of Elon musk's starlink terminals these
were game changing but they left the
country reliant on support from an
erratic billionaire the debilitating
Ukraine hack was also a wake-up call to
the commercial satellite industry almost
all of daily life turns on satellites
even Time commercial satellites
determine GPS coordinates that underpin
digital clocks and cash machines space
is playing an even bigger role in homes
transport food supply military
operations Banking and Communications
the risks are only set to rise today
there are close to 5 000 active
satellites on orbit in the next 10 years
that number could hit one hundred
thousand while Andreas wickberg waited
on one of the 45
000 plus replacement modems ViaSat was
busy sending out
decided to mail a faulty one to an
expert a week later Ruben santamata
opened the package thrilled a leading
light in a very small Global band of
cyber security researchers who are
obsessed with satellite systems Santa
Marta immediately pulled the modem apart
and dumped What's called the flash
memory that's the part of the device
that stores key rewritable data in place
of a series of word strings and numbers
common to code in working modems he
found orderly repetition far from a
temporary glitch the destructive pattern
indicated a malware attack ViaSat
admitted the attack was preventable but
said they hadn't had the capability to
stop it an attacker they said had
exploited a misconfiguration in a
virtual private Network Appliance via a
gram-based network intrusion to gain
remote access to a trusted management
segment of the KSAT Network in other
words they got hacked pretty bad it took
four weeks for the U.S intelligence
Community to conclude Russia's Military
Intelligence unit the gru carried out
the attack the U.S then embarked on a
six-week quiet diplomatic pain to
publicly blame it on Russia an unusual
step that made some European countries
including France and Germany nervous in
case it made things worse but the
argument went that this was the most
important Cyber attack of the Russian
invasion one no one who subscribed to
the service could do anything to stop
and one that could happen again
eventually the European Union went
public with the U.S careful to go second
an effort to send a signal to Russia
that everyone was United the final
frontier is still vastly underprepared
for cyber attacks commercial satellite
companies are still too lacks when it
comes to security and some government
satellite systems were built 30 40 years
ago making them especially vulnerable
starlink's Ukraine service has already
faced attacks of their own and ViaSat
says it faces ongoing threats Russia has
publicly warned since the invasion it
sees some commercial satellites as
legitimate targets for retaliation the
U.S intelligence Community says Moscow
will seek weapons that can identify
track and Target U.S satellites at speed
during a conflict and the attack say
experts is super super repeatable
foreign
[Music]